هل يمكن مساواه ضباط الشرطه بالاطباء
لناحيه شروط الاستقاله هذا ما يطالب به
احد النواب في محاوله لمنع استقالات
الاطباء الشباب التي تؤدي لعجز في
المنظومه الصحيه
النائب عاطف مغاوري يدافع عن مقترحه بعدم
قبول الاستقاله الا بعد قضاء عشر سنوات في
مستشفيات الدوله او دفع ثلاثه اضعاف
تكاليف الدراسه الجامعيه رابط الشرطه لما
بيستقيل بيستقيل بحثا عن تحقيق مصلحه
وانفعه اعلى من وجوده كضابط شرطه فهو
يستقيق ايضا الطبيب بيستقيل هيستقيل لانه
يرى في نفسه سواء هيعمل مستشفيات خاصه او
هيعمل لدى الخارج فهو بيقرر الاستقامه اذا
بحثا عن ميزه امام هذه الميزه انا انفقت
عليك على الجانب الاخر ترى نقابه الاطباء
ان الانفاق على طالب الكليات العسكريه من
اقامه واعاشه وتعليم يختلف تماما عن
الانفاق على طلاب كليه الطب اضافه الى عدم
وجود مساواه في الرواتب والمزايا الوظيفيه
بين الفريقين بعد التخرج كلنا عايزين نعيش
في البلد دي
طب ما انت دور سيدي البرلماني على اسباب
اللي خلت الراجل ده يستقيل ان خلت الراجل
ده
يقدم على هجره ويسافر للهجره والا احنا
ممكن بعد فتره هيحصل تصحر طبي الامر لم
يكن غائبا عن اطباء المستقبل الذين
وجدناهم متابعينا لهذا الخبر وتباينت نحوه
ردود فعلهم وان كانت الغالبيه منهم تعرضه
لانهم بالفعل يفكرون في السفر
شايفه ناس معايا في الجامعه من سنه اولى
بيفكروا في عمل معادله والسفر بره طب ليه
يعني يعني طبعا هي فكره حلوه لان احنا
عندنا عجز كبير قوي يعني احنا محتاجين
فعلا اطباء احنا كل الكوادر الطبيه
الكويسه بتطلع بره
منطقيه يعني هو مش جيش وغير كده كده انت
بمجرد ما بتتخرج او مش بتتخرج سنه خمسه او
سته انت بتشتغل في الامتياز احنا عندنا
نظام سنتين سياسي كده هتخدم البلد عشر
سنين شايفها انهم تكون ثقيله ممكن ممكن
اوافق لو مده تبقى اقل هذا الاقتراح اللي
انا يعني طرحته ومتبني لن يناقش ولن
يستكمل الا في ظل منظومه منها منها فكره
القانون المسؤوليه الطبيه ومنها ايضا كادر
الطب
والمرتبات طلاب الطب يعلمون يقينا بالظروف
العمل الحكومي قبل دخول الكليه وهو ما
يستند اليه النائب في مقترحه ولكن في
الوقت نفسه يرى اخرون انه يحق لهم البحث
عن الحياه الكريمه التي تعب دراسيا من
اجلها تامر نصرت العربيه القاهره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات